nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir cet
après-midi Madame Valérie PCR présidente
de la région île-defance et présidente
d'î de d'Île de France mobilité c'est en
cette dernière qualité que nous avons
invité nousavons invité à intervenir
devant notre commission dans le cadre de
l'examen de la proposition de loi
relative à l'ouverture à la concurrence
du réseau de bus francilien déposé par
notre collègue Vincent capo Canella que
je sal car il est présent aujourd'hui
parmi nous ce texte qui comporte h
articles vise à répondre à plusieurs
difficultés rencontré par la RATP et
île-de-fance mobilité dans la transition
vers le régime concurrentiel prévu par
le législateur pour le 1er janvier
2025 il est apparu que l'organisation de
cette ouverture à la concurrence
nécessitait diverses mesures
transitoires de niveau législatif afin
d'assurer la continuité du service
public et la fluidité de la transition
entre la ATP les futurs exploitants dans
l'intérêt des voyageurs la loi du 24
décembre 2019 d'orientation des
mobilités dite loi l'homme dont Didier
Mandelli avait été le rapporteur a
défini de nombreuses mesures et garantie
d'ordre social et le transfert aux
nouveaux attributaires de contrat de
travail des salariés concurrents à
concourrant à l'exploitation des
services concernés ainsi que la
portabilité de certains droits issus du
statut de salarié de la RATP depuis 2019
toutefois de nouvelles difficultés
sociales et
opérationnelles difficilement
prévisibles ont émergé cette proposition
de loi comporte diverses dispositions
pour y répondre pour laisser
suffisamment de temps au bon déroulement
du processus d'ouverture à la
concurrence ce texte offre à
Île-de-France mobilité la possibilité de
décaler pour une durée qu'elle fixe mais
ne pouvant dépasser 2 ans la date de
cette ouverture son objectif principal
est d'assurer la continuité la qualité
du du service notamment lors des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques qui
solliciteront fortement les capacités
des transports franiliens l'été prochain
mais également de faire en sorte que le
changement éventuel d'exploitant se
déroule dans les meilleures conditions
possibles madame la Présidente je vous
poserai quelques questions générales
pour amorcer les échanges et vous
indiquer notre état d'esprit nous
souhaiterions que vous partagiez
l'opinion d'Île-de-France mobilité
l'autorité organisatrice des transports
en région capitale par rapport à ce
processus d'ouverture à la concurrence
les perspectives qu'elle ouvre les défis
qu'elle implique et les inquiétudes
qu'elle génère comment au sein
d'Île-de-France mobilité cette échéance
Estelle anticipée quel est votre avis
concernant le délai de 2 ans laisser à
Île-de-France
mobilité pour aménager le calendrier
d'ouverture à la concurrence serez-vous
prêt pour le 31 décembre 2024 où cette
souplesse est-elle bienvenue je rappelle
que le gouvernement a engagé la
procédure accéléré pour l'examen de
cette PPL jamais procédure n'aura aussi
bien porté son nom car le délai d'examen
sont extrêmement serré cette proposition
de loi sera discutée en séance publique
le lundi 23 octobre prochain et
éventuellement le mardi 24 si le temps
d'examen de la PPL sererme occupe plus
de temps qu'anticipé lors de la séance
du lundi par conséquent son examen en
commission interviendra dès la semaine
prochaine le mercredi 18 octobre
prochain je remercie le rapporteur Fran
dersin pour qui cet exercice était une
première fois d'avoir conduit un
programme d'audition particulièrement
dense afin d'entendre tous les acteurs
et de pouvoir éclairer au mieux les
travaux de la commission sur un texte
tout autant technique que
politique à l'issue de votre
intervention euh je céderai la parole à
mes collègues qui auront qui mquont pas
l'occasion de vous poser un certain
nombre de questions madame la Présidente
je vous cède la parole merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs je vais essayer de de de vous
faire assez court parce que l'objectif
de de de cette loi elle est simple
l'objectif de cette loi de cette
proposition de loi pour moi ça doit être
de de mettre en œuvre un certain nombre
de propositions qui ont été faites par
Jean Grosset et Jean-Claude baahli à
l'occasion d'une d'une vraie
concertation qui a été menée avec
l'ensemble des personnels de la RATP y
compris les organisations syndicales
afin de de procéder dans les meilleures
conditions possibles à l'ouverture à la
concurrence du réseau de bus RATP alors
vous le savez l'ouverture à la
concurrence du réseau de bus
d'Île-de-France a commencé à partir de
2021 la loi fixait le 30 décembre 2020
pour cette ouverture et nous avons lancé
le processus donc en janvier 2021 mais
et c'est ça ça qui est intéressant et
c'est ça que je veux porter à votre
connaissance et un petit peu vous faire
un retour d'expérience sur ce qui s'est
passé en grande couronne nous avons
étalé sur 3 ans puisque nous venons de
terminer l'ouverture à la à la
concurrence progressive de l'ensemble de
ces réseaux il y avait combien de
réseaux 36 et 36 réseaux de bus de la
grande couronne c'est important de
savoir qu'il y a déjà 36 réseaux de bus
en î-defance ouvert à la délégation de
service public la RATP représente que 12
lot supplémentaire en plus de ces 36
alors moi ce que je vous ai proposerai
volontiers et je crois
que c'est ce que Vincent capocanelas a
retenu comme comme méthode c'est c'est
de de
dupliquer la méthode que nous avons
utilisé sur la grande couronne sur Paris
Centre c'est-à-dire une ouverture à la
concurrence
progressive alors le bilan quand même de
cette ouverture la concurrence j'y tiens
parce que en quelques mots parce parce
que il y a quand même beaucoup de choses
fausses qui ont été dites le bilan est
globalement positif pour les voyageurs
c'est vrai que à chaque ouverture à la
concurrence quand on change de
délégataire de service public et vous
connaissez ça dans vos territoirees
puisque tous les territoires de France
sont dans délégation de service public
il n'y a plus aujourd'hui que la RATP
qui est en monopole sur Paris tous les
territoires sont délégation de service
public quand on change le délégataire
d'une délégation de transport il y a
toujours une petite période un peu
compliquée de transition à
le sortant ne laissant pas forcément les
matériels en meilleur état
emportant parfois avec lui un certain
nombre de salariés pour les emmener sur
un autre territoire et cetera donc c'est
ce qui s'est passé évidemment quand on a
ouvert les premiers lots enfin plus
exactement à chaque fois qu'on ouvre un
lot et que la tributaire n'est pas le
sortant il y a des petites frictions de
démarrage voilà c'est encore le cas à
cette rentrée sur le lot de Versailles
qui est passé de Kolis à transdè c'est
aussi enfin c'est voilà c'est le cas à
chaque fois voilà alors mais si on
regarde sur la durée c'est-à-dire les
lots qui ont été ouverts il y a 2 ans
par exemple on voit clairement une
amélioration du service parce que dans
le cadre de de l'ouverture à la
concurrence dans le cadre de la
délégation de service public on a
demander plus de service une meilleure
qualité et on voit aussi des nouvelles
offres de servicees par les concurrents
en LCE donc on voit par exemple que les
lignes qui ont été ouvertes en DSP après
au bout d'un an
d'exploitation la ponctualité de + 2 %
sur les lignes Transdev plus 4 % sur les
lignes Keolis plus 5 % pour les lignes
opérées par la RTP cap en Île-de-France
parce que le paradoxe parce que ça n'en
est pas un mais certains la RATP ne
veulent pas l'ouverture la concurrence
pour la RATP la RATP concourt évidemment
aux lignes mises en concurrence en
grande couronne donc gagne des marchés
en grande couronne sur ses concurrents
euh plus de servicees alors quand je dis
plus de service beaucoup sur la sécurité
euh et puis aussi sur les
correspondances avec les trains parce
que vous savez que le réseau de bus ben
évidemment il doit être coordonné avec
les trains et ça c'est vraiment très
important plus d'exigence aussi puisque
dans nos DSP nos nouvelles DSP on a mis
des bonus malus qui repose à 50 % sur la
régularité et à 30 % sur des indicateurs
de qualité qui sont mesurés par des
clients mystère que nous missionnons
alors évidemment c'est c'est tout
nouveau comme méthode mais enfin c'est
l'évaluation par les clients et puis on
a fait aussi on fait aussi une enquête
perceptionprès des usagers qui est
réalisé par île- de France mobilité qui
compte pour 20 % de du cahier des
charges alors baay et Grosset donc ont
été mandatés quand nous avons vu que il
y avait des tensions à la RATP et
surtout quand nous avons identifié que
peut-être la loi l'omme avait été un peu
vite en besogne quand elle a fixé un
certain nombre de dispositions
législatives d'où la nécessité du d'une
loi pour pour organiser dans de bonnes
conditions les garanties sociales qui
vont être données aux agents de la RATP
alors ce que j'ai proposé ce je propose
au législateur c'est que on garde le
même la même méthode pour donc
l'ouverture à la concurrence du réseau
RATP donc un calendrier
échelonné le réseau de ligne de bus de
Paris de la petite couronne représente
un ensemble qui est important qui est
cohérent et qui est massif c'est 5000
bus euh et donc chacun des 13 lots
représente à peu près l'équivalent
chacun des 13 lots l'équivalent de la
mise en service d'un réseau comme celui
de Rennes ou celui de Nantes donc c'est
13 fois Rennes ou 13 fois Nantes voilà à
peu près le calendrier qu'on a retenu
c'est donc le suivant ce serait de
commencer à attribuer les contrats après
les Jeux Olympiques donc à l'automne
2024 et jusqu'en octobre 2025 ça c'est
pour l'attribution des contrats mais
entre le moment où on a attribue le
contrat et le moment où on transfère
vraiment
euh les actifs il s'écoule
9 9 mois à peu près euh
ou de 9 à 12 mois et l'intérêt c'est que
le lauréat du coup peut préparer mieux
le démarrage du contrat c'est vraiment
les retours d'expérience qu'on a eu ben
je vous dis de ces de ces de ces
transferts d'opérateurs qui se passai
pas très bien de ces bus en mauvais état
qui étaient légué au suivant et cetera
je pense que avoir ne9 12 mois pour
préparer la mise en uvre du contrat
c'est bien euh et le l'idée d'avoir un
processus continu donc de d'ouverture de
janvier 2025 à décembre 2026 ça permet
d'être dans une logique d'amélioration
continue aussi c'estàd on commence par
les lots les plus simples les plus
faciles pour aller vers les lots les
plus complexes les deux lots les plus
complexes c'est Paris il n'y a que deux
lots sur les 13 qui sont dans Paris
intramuros tous les autres sont à
l'extérieur de Paris
voilà
alors qu'est-ce que Messieurs Grosset et
bi ont on ont vu comme problème les qui
nécessite une intervention
législateur ils ont vu trois sujets qui
inquiètent les agents et qui mérite
qu'on leur donne des avantages sociaux
supplémentaires alors ces avantages
supplémentaires sociaux pour les agents
de la RATP c'est un de limiter leur
changement de lieu de travail en fait le
décret actuel euh qui était conforme à
la volonté du législateur de l'époque
disait que les 17000 agents des
centrebus machinistes mainteneur
contrôleur serait maintenu sur la même
ligne en cas de transfert du réseau à
are opérateur en fait il faut pas dire
sur la même ligne il faut dire sur le
même dépôt sur le même site voilà c'est
important parce que évidemment la ligne
parfois elle est très très longue et
donc ça pourrait donner lieu à des à des
transferts à des déménagements ça a
inquiétait beaucoup les agents donc nous
on est tout tout à fait prêt et tous les
opérateurs sont prêts à dire qu'ils sont
gardés sur le même dépôt la vérité c'est
qu'on veut garder les mêmes agents au
même endroit donc en fait c'est la
logique donc limiter et changement de
lieu de travail deuxièmement limiter les
transferts de personnels en excluant les
personnels du siège c'est-à-dire la RATP
a beaucoup de turnover un gros taux de
départ à la retraite donc elle est
d'accord pour absorber les personnels du
siège qui gèent aujourd'hui les réseaux
de bus et que il y ait pas de transfert
de ces personnels du siège à la RATP ils
restent à la RATP ils seront redéployés
dans dans l'univers RATP et en revanche
les opérateurs alternatifs qui
gagneraient des des réseaux eux
recruteront pour leur sièges des des des
personnel dédiés donc on transfère pas
euh on exclut les personnels du siège
donc ça fait 700 salariés qui seront
transférés en moins potentiellement hein
parce que là encore on part du principe
quand on fait la loi on parle d'un
principe maximaliste qui serait que la
RTP perdrait tous ses lots elle peut
être reconduite à 80 % à 90 % à 70 %, on
sait pas du tout à combien de pourcent
la RATP va être re conduite en réalité
il est vraisemblable on a on a regardé
sur la grande couronne très intéressant
parce qu'il y a eu des changements
évidemment d'opérateur mais globalement
les équilibres ont été à peu près
préservés donc il est possible que la
RATP soit reconduite sur de nombreux
lots mais en tout cas il y a 700
salariés qui sont concernés au siège par
la gestion des réseaux de bus c'est 700
salariés restent grâce à ce cette
proposition de loi au sein de la RATP la
troisème avantage social supplémentaire
garantie sociale supplémentaire c'est
que île- de France mobilité va récupérer
en propre certaines missions
stratégiques du réseau de bus et ces
missions stratégiques c'est la
supervision du trafic la coordination
opérationnelle des opérateurs en cas
d'incident pour mieux gérer
l'information des voyageurs ça veut dire
que nous allons récupérer une trentaine
d'agents de la RATP qui vont venir chez
IDFM notamment pour gérer l'information
voyageur en service perturbé parce que
évidemment on a intérêt à concentrer
l'information et à et à la centraliser
chez nous donc c'est un nouveau métier
qui va arrivver à Île-de-France mobilité
donc on a déjà pris contact avec l'État
si la loi était adoptée pour travailler
sans délai sur les modification du
décret d'application de la loi alors par
ailleurs et au-delà de des textes moi je
veux devant vous prendre trois
engagements supplémentaires vis-à-vis
des collaborateurs de la RATP euh
d'abord comme pour les bus de grande
couronne île- de- France mobilité
imposera aux nouveaux opérateurs de
maintenir les conditions sociale dont
bénéficient aujourd'hui les agents de la
RATP en effet il faut savoir que les
conditions sociales mais je pense que ça
n'est pas un mystère pour vous les
conditions sociales des agents de la
RATP sont supérieures à celles aux
conditions sociales socle qui sont fixés
par le décret du cadre social
territorial et qui s'applique donc aux
autres opérateurs français donc le sujet
c'était est-ce que on peut demander de
maintenir les conditions sociales de la
RATP pour les agents qui sont déjà
salari de la RATP c'est SK de France
mobilité demandera l ses appels d'offre
aux nouveaux opérateurs ce qui permet
évidemment de tranquilliser des agents
notamment sur des régimes de retraite
qui sont un peu spécifiques et cetera
ensuite j'ai décidé que les conditions
sociales seraiit préservé les conditions
sociales de la RATP seraient préservé
pour l'ensemble des machinistes des
dépôts de bus quel que soit la ligne de
bus alors c'est un peu technique mais il
se trouve que l'État je ne sais pas
pourquoi dans sa grande sagesse avait
exclu certains territoires du cadre
social territorial en fait l'État a pris
un périmètre du cadre social territorial
qui est plus petit que le réseau RATP
existant il y a des lignes RATP en
dehors du cadre social territorial
évidemment les agents qui sont sur ces
lignes qui sont en dehors du cadre
social territorial donc je n'ai pas
compris pourquoi il ne reprenaient pas
les le tracé des 13 des 13 lot RATP mais
enfin bon typiquement des agents qui
sont en en en bordure de la Grande
Couronne ne serait pas concerné par le
cadre social territorial nous les
réintégrons et nous demanderons aux
opérateurs qu' soient traités comme les
agents du cadre social territorial et
enfin sur la sécurité du réseau parce
que c'est très important évidemment euh
on va inclure dans les nouveaux contrats
de DSP de délégation de service public
l'obligation pour l'opérateur de
recruter des agents de sécurité
supplémentaire donc ça c'est pour donner
un j'allais dire un plus encore à la
sécurité sur le réseau pourquoi parce
que la RATP a un service le GPSR qui est
un service de sécurité global pour
l'ensemble de l'entreprise et donc il y
avait une petite angoisse notamment des
opérateurs alternatifs mais aussi les
agents qu'il y ait moins d'agents de
sûreté du coup sur les réseaux si
c'était plus opéré par la RATP voilà
donc au total on aura 400 agents de
sûreté supplémentaires qui seront prévus
dans les contrats de bus à Paris et en
petite couronne et qui s'ajouteront et
alors c'est intéressant parce que
supposeer que la RATP soit reconduite
euh ça n'empêchera pas que les agents
supplémentaires seront quand même
recrutés c'est vraiment IDFM qui met sur
la table l'argent du recrutement de 400
agents de sécurité supplémentair pour le
réseau de bus Paris petite couronne ce
qui est vraiment important comp tenu
vous le savez malheureusement président
de la montée et la recruesens des
incivilités voire des agressions euh
voir des agressions sexité sexuelle euh
sur voir des agressions au conducteurs
et au machinistes et au et aux
contrôleurs pardon dans les réseaux de
bus Paris petite couronne donc vraiment
je tiens à le dire et à le réaffirmer
devant la représentation nationale c'est
un cadre social extrêmement protectateur
que met en place IDFM mais un cadre
social protecteur dont nous sommes
convaincus qu'il n'empêchera pas grâce à
l'ouverture de la concurrence des gains
de productivité et des gain de qualité
de service
voilà merci madame la Présidente pour ce
propos liminaire je vais maintenant
donner la parole au rapporteur et à
l'issue à mes collègues j'ai deux
demandes de parole et puis je donnerai
la parole aussi à Vincent s'il le
souhaite
oui euh madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues c'est pour
moi évidemment un honneur que d'avoir
été nommé rapporteur de cette
proposition de loi et donc je suis je
dirais assez ému de m'exprimer pour la
première fois en cette qualité et puis
devant vous madame PCR ça ne nous
rajogit pas puisqu'on se connaît depuis
plus de 25
ans oui oui
effectivement bien donc c'est un
exercice dont je mesure pleinement les
responsabilités et à l'on des auditions
que j'ai conduite c'est en effet donc
vers le rapporteur que converge donc de
nombreux cadeaux
d'information et que se cristallise les
les positions des
acteurs charge à lui évidemment opérer
la délicate synthèse d'une somme
substantielle de de données techniques
et et et d'analysees juridique et
évidemment de tirer les conséquences
législatives concrètes de ces échanges
pour fluidifier la qualité du processus
d'ouverture à la concurrence belle et
noble mission bien
évidemment j'ai déjà requis l'avis et
l'analyse donc de la DG ITM de la RT du
SGAE d'optil des syndicats
représentatifs du personnel de la RATP
et de la fnot euh ces échanges m'ont
fait prendre conscience tout d'abord de
l'ampleur du défi technique opérationnel
et et social que constitue donc
l'ouverture à la concurrence du réseau
de bus franidien de la RATP euh des
inquiétudes existent ça nous le savons
tous les syndicats surtout hein
s'interroge sur le bien fondé évidemment
de cette ouverture à la concurrence et
sur la capacité des nouveaux opérateurs
donc à répondre au aux attentes sociales
fortes des personnels dans un contexte
économique évidemment particulier une
fréquentation qui n'a pas retrouvé son
niveau d'avant covid mais c'est vrai
partout en France y compris dans ma
région des opérateurs de transport qui
font face à des difficultés
structurelles de recrutement mais là
aussi c'est vrai partout et les
incertitudes de calendrier qui génèrent
de l'anxiété professionnelle alors les
usagers compte à eux espèrent une
amélioration de la qualité et de l'offre
et du service grâce donc au passage à un
marché concur cel mais évidemment il
redoute un peu des bénéfices en
demi-teinte ces craintes sont bien
réelles et il faut évidemment les
entendes dans l'intérêt même des
voyageurs et de la continuité du service
public que nous avons tous à cœur je
sais que c'est une conviction forte de
l'auteur de cette proposition de loi
notre collègue Vincent
capocanela c'est aussi ma conviction oui
évidemment à la concurrence qui profite
aux usagers à la qualité de service non
à un processus mal préparé qui n'apporte
aucun des bénéfices que l'on peut
attendre d'une mise en
concurrence je n'apprends évidemment à
personne que les Jeux Olympiques et
parolympiques auront lieu à Paris l'été
prochain et la désorganisation des
transports publics de voyageurs
donnerait évidemment de la France une
très mauvaise image alors madame la
Présidente ma ma première question porte
assez naturellement sur la manière dont
île-de-fance mobilité envisage
aujourd'hui donc le processus
d'ouverture à la urrence au regard des
appels d'offres qui ont déjà été lancés
et des évolutions qui sont intervenues
depuis la loi d'orientation des
mobilités de 2019 dont la moindre n'est
pas la pandémie et ces profonds
bouleversement socio-économique alors
j'entends parfois le terme de report
régulièrement alors il n'est pas exact
en vérité la loi la proposition de loi
privilégie un échelonnement donc des
attributions de délégation des services
publics en 2025 et 2026 selon donc un
calendrier laissz à votre appréciation
et au sein d'une fourchette temporelle
de 2 ans donc est-ceela selon vous une
disposition bienvenue qui permet de
mieux séquencer fluidifier le processus
d'ouverture à la
concurrence pour parler concrètement
l'état du droit le 1er janvier 2025
verrait donc le transfert simultané de
19 salariés de 19000 pardon salariés 308
lignes de bus 4500 bus vers des nouveaux
opérates
Île de France mobilité est-il donc
préparé prêt et dimensionné pour faire
face à ces transferts massifs en
l'espace non seulement d'une seule
journée mais pratiquement d'une seule
nuit si on peut parler comme ça alors
cela m'amène aussi logiquement à la
question donc des moyens d'Île-de-
France mobilité c'est Leir de la guerre
évidemment mais aussi des transport
public les agences de notation indiquent
des perspectives négatives pour le
profil de crédit d'Île-de- France
mobilité alors que nous sommes passés en
l'espace d'un an d'une dette publique
finançable à des taux négatifs et à des
taux qui tangentent aujourd'hui les 4 %
donc disposez-vous des capacités des
moyens nécessaires pour faire face à la
montée en puissance substantielle des
charges d'organisation et de super et de
supervision du fait du passage d'un
opérateur unique à une
multiplicité donc de délégataire je
pense également à à la reprise des
personnels très qualif du du cri vous
savez le le centre d'information et de
régulation voyageur qui emploie environ
350 personnes c'est peu mais ils ont une
responsabilité énorme et car ils sont en
charge du du pilotage en temps réel de
l'intégralité des lignes de bus afin
d'assurer donc la surveillance du réseau
qui est le réseau le plus dense de
France la régulation du trafic
l'information voyageur les incidents et
bien nombre d'autres choses ce seront
autant de métier et de mission nouvelle
exercé comment donc île- de- France
mobilité se prépare-t-il à ces échéances
l'article 2 la proposition de loi qui
élargit les possibilités de recrutement
répond-il à ces nouveaux besoins
opérationnels et à la spécialisation
accrue de l'organigramme d'î de France
mobilité qui en découlera je m'interroge
également sur les hypothèses et les
réflexions qui ont guidé î de France
mobilité dans l'affectation des lignes
des centesbus bus au aux 12 lignes au 12
lots ouverts à la concurrence quelles
ont été je dirais les les idées
directrices pour améliorer le service au
voyageurs fluidifier les transferts de
personnel de l'pic RATP vers les
nouveaux opérateurs et rationaliser donc
les regroupements de centrebus en vue de
faciliter l'exploitation des lignes
concernant le choix de retenir l'unité
centrebus pour le transfert des
personnels qui limitent donc fortement
les cas de mobilité
géographique qui qui sont contraintes
hein mais mais qui conduit à des
surtransferts dans C certains cas et des
soustransferts évidemment dont d'autres
donc comment ilî-defance mobilité
envisage-t-il la mise en œuvre du
volontariat pour les personnels qui
souhaitent par exemple changer de
centrebus pour rester sur la même ligne
de bus cette double règle de de décision
conduit évidemment à des difficulté de
de gestion des des contrats de travail
transférés et qui inquiète bien
évidemment ils me l'ont dit les syndicat
que j'ai entendu hier sur le
voilà sur le fondement si vous voulez de
de de quels critères également et règles
de décision comptez-vous faire je dirais
droit à ce volontariat j'ai également
une question concernant les les
bienfaits attendus de cette ouverture à
à la concurrence une petite idée
évidemment je la pratique chez moi la
théorie économique néoclassique postule
plusieurs types de bénéfices de nature
donc à stimuler la la compétitivité et
la productivité des acteurs élargir
l'offre et améliorer la qualité des
services tout en faisant évidemment
baisser les prix pour les usagers qu'en
espère ilî de France mobilité au regard
notamment de la régularité du
trafic de la qualité des services de
l'information au voyageurs et évidemment
du coût des transports j'ai l'impression
que nous n'allons pas vers une
diminution du prix des billets avec
l'augmentation du coût d'exploitation du
fait même de l'inflation et la
nécessaire transition énergétique qui
conduit donc à électrifier la flotte
avec des bus électriques dont le coût
d'acquisition on le sait est presque
doublé par rapport à celui d'un véhicule
thermique alors confirmez-vous cette
cette analyse euh île- de France
mobilité profitera-t-il de cette
ouverture à la concurrence pour
rehausser le niveau des pénalités mais
vous en avez un petit peu parlé euh tout
à l'heure dans vos propos hein en cas de
non respect des engagements contractuels
des opérateurs donc vis-à-vis de
l'autorité organisatrice quelle mesure
comptez-vous mettre en œuvre afin de
parvenir à un niveau concurrentiel tel
que les bienfaits de la concurrence
postulé donc par la théorie puiss se
réaliser en pratique et concernant la
question essentielle des données
d'exploitation nécessairirees aux futurs
concurrents pour répondre aux appels
d'offre disposez-vous bien de la
capacité à lever ses barrières à
l'entrée de type informationnel j'aurai
enfin une dernière interrogation afin de
laisser également le temps à mes
collègues de poser leurs questions que
pensez-vous de la proposition qui
consiste à confier à la RT un pouvoir de
règlement des différents entre île-de-
France mobilité et la RATP concernant
donc le nom de salariés dont le contrat
se poursuit auprès des nouveaux
employeurs est-ce selon vous la bonne
autorité pour trancher ce type de litige
pensez-vous qu'il soit opportun de
confier ce rôle à une autre instance
voilà je vous
remercie m'avoir écouté merci monsieur
le rapporteur madame la Présidente si
vous voulez répondre au rapporteur
oui tous les appels d'offre ont été
lancés déjà donc donc oui on est prêt et
en réalité alors je vais vous dire un
secret il n'a jamais été dans notre dans
notre idée de tout transférer le 1er
janvier 2025 jamais de jamais voilà la
loi disait 1er janvier 2025 mais
effectivement ce que vous avez dit tout
à fait juste 15000 salariés du jour au
lendemain dont le sort peut changer là
encore je le dis avec des des guillemets
parce que la vérité c'est que la RATP
peut tout à fait être reconduite sur un
grand nombre de Cellot mais
effectivement
donner les résultats pour tout le monde
le même jour et même pour les opérateurs
alternatifs absorber l'arrivé de
potentiel de milliers de de de personnel
supplémentaires ça n'aurait d'ailleurs
ça aurait risqué de conduire à un manque
de concurrence parce que les opérateurs
auraient du coup pu se concentrer sur un
ou deux lots en se disant je candidate
pas sur tous les lots parce que si je
dois tous les opérer le le jourg c'est
impossible donc nous n'avons jamais eu
l'intention d'appliquer la loi
strictement au premier 1er janvier 2025
comme nous n'avons pas appliqué
strictement au 1er janvier 2021 la loi
sur la grande couronne pourquoi parce
que c'est matériellement impossible
socialement économiquement
opérationnellement donc ça c'est
important en revanche reporter cette
date du 1er janvier 2025 je me'y suis
opposé de toutes mes forces qui marque
le point de départ du processus pourquoi
mais tout simplement parce que je vois
bien derrière qu'il y a aussi des forces
politiques qui ont envie du maintien du
monopole de la rat et sur Paris je ne
crois pas que ce monopole soit une bonne
chose sur le long terme je pense que la
loi européenne nous nous invite à à
challenger ce monopole l'ensemble des
métropoles de France sont en délégation
de service public ça permet quand même
tous les 5 ans de remettre les compteurs
à zéro et tous les 5 ans de se faire un
petit point sur la qualité de service et
tous les 5 ans de vous de rebaser un
petit peu les relations et je trouve que
c'est une bonne et une saine R
aspiration et je le dis d'autant plus
que ceux qui aujourd'hui nous disent
c'est quand même mieux le monopole que
l'ouverture à la concurrence euh bon ils
ont vécu comme moi l'automne 2022 qui a
été un automne tragique pour la RATP où
on a eu 25 % de services non faits par
le monopole public sur les bus parisiens
25 % de services non réalisés parce que
on a vécu la grande démission on a vécu
une démobilisation des agents il y avait
pas de patron à la rat
et puis il y avait il faut quand même le
dire peut-être un mouvement social larvé
anticoncurrence qui s'est greffé
là-dessus bref on n'a pas complètement
toutes les toutes les tenants et les
aboutissants mais il faut savoir que le
la pénurie de conducteur en
Île-de-France c'était Mo- 8 % de service
sur les autres lignes et sur les Lig
RATP c'était Mo- 25 %. on n'a pas pu
vraiment prouver les vertus du monopole
en tout cas au printemps 2022 ce qui a
été plutôt prouvé c'est que sur les les
DSP de grande couronne on arrivit plus
rapidement et de manière plus agile à
lutter contre la grande démission qu'à
la RATP où il a fallu faire un énorme
plan de recrutement j'allais dire massif
donc voilà donc donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de ne pas repousser cette cette
date du 1er janvier 2025 mais évidemment
de le faire de manière assez habile
parce que 2026 c'est les municipales y
compris les municipales à Paris nous ne
voulons pas que l'ouverture à la
concurrence soit prise en otage dans le
cadre d'une joue politique 2027 c'est la
présidentielle donc ce serait quand même
bien que tout soit terminé avant de
façon à ce qu'on puisse prouver pour
cette présidentielle que on est capable
de mettre en œuvre la la concurrence de
manière tranquille et sereine en dehors
de moments qui sont des moments
d'hystérisation on le sait bien de la
vie politique c'est en tout cas ma thèse
euh alors les perspectives négatives
pour les finances d'idfm c'est très
important que vous en parliez j'en
profite pour lancer un appel au Sénat
puisque bientôt viendra devant vous le
projet de loi de finan euh oui qu'est-ce
qui se passe euh île- de- France
mobilité va se voir transférer alors ça
n'a rien à voir avec les bus mais va se
voir transférer entre
2024 et 2031 la responsabilité d'ouvrir
330 km supplémentaires de ligne de métro
330 km ça veut dire qu'on va doubler le
réseau de métro parisien je je suis à
votre disposition pour en parler quand
vous voulez on va le doubler on va
transférer la la société du Grand Paris
à î- de France mobilité la gestion de 70
nouvelles gares alors je vous rassure si
on nous les transfèt c'est parce
qu'elles vont être lourdement
déficitaire chacune puisque ces gares
ont été conçus comme des gestes
architecturaux et non pas comme des
centres de profit avec des bureaux ou
des centres commerciaux c'est vraiment
des gares voilà des des des avec des
architectures extrêmement spectaculaires
qui vont être à entretenir très cher
voilà donc évidemment les transferts je
suis devant le Sénat le Sénat s'est
battu pour pour que on reconnaisse comme
inconstitutionnel les transferts de
compétences qui ne seraient pas compensé
à l'euro prê on en est archi loin voilà
voilà donc le sujet c'est pour ça qu'il
y a des perspectives négatives sur les
finances d'idfm parce que bah les
agences de notation voient arriver cette
charge d'exploitation qui représente 800
millions de plus en
2024 mais qui représentera 2 milliards 7
de plus en 2031 ils voit cette cet
argent et ils se disent mais où est-ce
qu'idfm va le trouver par ailleurs ils
ont bien entendu président de la
République dire que il voulait un
passerail à 49 € et comme il voit que le
Pass Navigo d'Île-de-France mobilité est
déjà 94 € ils se disent comment ils vont
financer tout ça alors là aussi vous me
parlez de la baisse des prix des des
ticket
euh moi j'adore il y a des journalistes
qui disent Valérie PCR c'est contre la
baisse des prix mais qui est contre la
baisse des prix dans ce pays quel homme
ou quelle femme politique est contre la
baisse des prix on est tous pour si si
on pouvait tous tout faire gratuitement
on le ferait si on dit qu'on ne le fait
pas c'est juste parce qu'on est des
hommes et des femmes responsable et
qu'on sait bien que tout tout a un prix
et qu'il y a bien quelqu'un qui paye à
la fin donc évidemment comme tous les
Français j'adorerais que le Pass Navigo
en î-defrance soit à 49 €. mais alors là
pour le coup si on le faisait à 49 €
c'est 1illard800 millions d'euros hein
qu'il faudrait trouver l'année prochaine
pas 800 millions 1ard800 million d'euros
de recette fiscales supplémentaire si le
Sénat est prêt à nous les voter mais à
un moment il faut me dire qui va les
payer ce milliard 800 millions parce que
moi j'ai fait des propositions on fait
payer les touristes les hôelier Râ j'ai
des proposs où on augmente le versement
mobilité puisquil s'appelle versement
mobilité c'est donc bien une redevance
pour service rendu par la mobilité
franilienne j'ai les entreprises qui
ralent les usagers ne veulent pas qu'on
augmente le Pass Navigo et les
collectivités alors je dois les saluer
aujourd'hui parce que je viens d'obtenir
aujourd'hui l'accord des six
départements d'île-de-fance y compris pr
la SC sais c'està-dire les C qui sont de
jeis dire de sensibilité de droite plus
la SC sais pour augmenter leur
contribution alors qu'ils n'ont plus de
DMTO ils vont augmenter leur
contribution a de France mobilité à
inflation plus 2 % pendant 5 ans chaque
année pendant 5 an inflation plus 2 %
par esprit de responsabilité pour
modérer les hausses de tarifs donc et la
région évidemment aussi montrera
l'exemple et sera inflation plus je n'ai
qu'un vote négatif de la ville de Paris
mais bon ça malheureusement vî de Paris
n'est pas majoritaire à île-de-fance
mobilité donc elle payera aussi
inflation + 2 c'est une dépense
obligatoire euh donc les collectivités
locales sont mobilisé tout le monde est
mobilisé mais monsieur le rapporteur
malheureusement je suis au regret de
vous dire la vérité toute nu
c'est-à-dire que ben quand on ouvre 330
km de ligne qu'on a besoin effectivement
vous l'avez dit de faire la transition
écologique du matériel roulant qu'on a
besoin d'investir qu'on a besoin que les
franciens ne prennent plus leur
voiturees on doit leur donner une
qualité de transport qui se paye voilà
et à un moment il y a toujours quelqu'un
qui paye mais je vous dis je suis
totalement ouverte si le Sénat a des
idées révolutionnaires pour trouver
l'argent
ailleurs mais il y aura forcément une
poche Pruse oui mais il y aura forcément
une poche faudra le prendre je vous le
dis parce que on a fait les assises du
financement des transports et on a
ouvert les chakras et ouvert toutes les
portes et les fenêtres tout le monde est
arrivé avec ses propositions il y a à la
fin toujours un contribuable qui paye il
faut se décider qu lequel c'est après on
peut avir ir des divergences politiques
sur qui doit payer mais à un moment il y
a toujours quelqu'un qui
paye sur les personnelles transférées
pour l'information voyageur on y est
prêt et on pense que ce sera une une
amélioration de de concentrer les choses
et je sais que les syndicats sont un peu
tendus là-dessus mais franchement c'est
pas la qualité de l'information voyageur
sur le réseau bus
francilien qui qui qui justifie qu'on
s'inquiète d'un transfert je pense qu'au
contraire ça améliorera beaucoup les
choses à la fin 12 lot pourquoi ben on
l'a fait avec la ATP c'est eux qui ont
voulu des lots assez gros on aurait pu
en faire 24 ils ont voulu 12 euh nous on
a fait ce qu'ils ont demander alors
maintenant évidemment le problème qu'on
a c'est toujours un petit peu le
problème quand on accompagne le
changement c'est que on nous a dit 24
lot c'est trop il en faut 12 ou 20 lot
c'est trop il en faut 12 maintenant on
nous dit 12 ils sont vraiment trop gros
ce serait bien si vous en aviez fait 20
euh les syndicats s'inquiétait que on
puisse pas rester dans le même dépôt et
maintenant monsieur le rapporteur vous
me dises ah oui mais et s'ils ont envie
de changer le dépôt vous avez prévu quoi
voilà à un moment donné le tramoou il
est sur pneus ou il est sur ou il est
sur rail vous voyez bon alors on débat
on concerte on se demande si c'est sur
roue ou si c'est sur rail mais un moment
on décide et la difficulté de de gérer
une grande collectivité mais je sais
qu'un certain nombre d'entre vous l'ont
déjà connu c'est que à un moment donné
faut décider c'est ou blanc ou c'est
noir ça peut pas être au milieu et donc
ben voilà on a décidé que c'était le
dépôt évidemment ça n'empêche absolument
pas des salariés qui voudraient changer
de dépôt de changer de dépôt il suffit
qu'ils en fassent la demande et je pense
que les opérateurs auront évidemment la
souplesse la souplesse qui va bien s'il
y a quelque chose à améliorer là-dessus
je peux aussi les réunir pour leur en
parler et leur dire leur dire les choses
mais je pense que c'est plus protecteur
d'être sûr qu'on peut garder son dépôt
et puis après de de proposer des
possibilités de mobilité volontaire euh
peut-être une petite un petit sujet
c'est c'est est-ce que que Monsieur
rapporteur vous n'auriez pas intérêt à
rencontrer Bay et Grosset pour qu'il
vous raconte aussi comment quelle a été
leur méthode de travail parce que elle
est vraiment elle a vraiment été tout à
fait respectueuse du dialogue social et
tout à fait inédite c'est avec bah et
Grosset aussi qu'on avait rédigé le
cahier des exigences sociales d'î de
France mobilité je crois qu'il est
unique en Europe donc je sais que on a
tendance à dire que en France on fait
rien avec de la concertation mais là en
l'occurrence franchement on a concerté à
fond
cette demande est en cours
madame alors sur les pénalités
renforcées effectivement c'est c'est ce
que vous avez dit vu je vous ai dit en
introduction et l'an derer maintenant
j'ai imposé le remboursement des
voyageurs quand le service n'est pas
fait ce qui est quelque chose de très
nouveau mais qui marche très très bien
l'année dernière on a remboursé tous les
usagers du réseau bus RATP l'année
dernière ils ont eu tous un
remboursement d'île-de France mobilité
payé par la RATP à cause du service qui
a pas été euh qui a pas été fait euh
voilà et sinon oui les informations
seront-elles suffisantes pour les
nouveaux opérateurs nous les obtiendront
euh on a on a le temps pour cela et la
RT réguler les litiges pourquoi pas
aucune objection de notre part
merci merci madame la Présidente devant
vous quitter parce que j'ai un
rendez-vous à l'extérieur je vais céder
la présidence à Didier Mandelli et
pendant ce temps je vais donner la
parole à phppe Tabar merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Président je voulais vous
poser de question vous avez déjà répondu
la question sur le bilan de de
l'ouverture à la concurrence sur la sur
la grande couronne deuxièmement détaill
quelques points du rapport gross que
vous avez également fait donc je me
permettrais simplement de de vous dire
que chacun peut
reconnaître chacun peut reconnaître que
vous ne ménagez pas vos efforts vous
avez
trouvé plutôt arraché peut-être un
accord historique au gouvernement sur le
financement d'idfn après des des années
de de silence du gouvernement de non
respect d'une parole donnée d'un certain
Édouard Philippe et
également je le dis l'opposition
semble-t-il d'après Le Figaro d'un
certain Bruno Le
Maire ensuite vous vous battez pour les
usagers pour amélior aurit l'offre et et
la qualité du du service de l'un des
plus gros réseaux de transport d'Europe
vous l'avez dit également qui prend
plusieurs millions de passagers
quotidiennement et qui vous l'avez dit
va doubler de taille d'ici 2030
j'entends mes collègues de province qui
sollicitent bien sûr des financements et
et ils ont tout à fait le droit de le
faire et notamment ceux qui dans le
futur vont mettre en place des
CERMES pour autant je je rappelle
que de par cette cette multiplication
par de de la taille du réseau on est
obligé nous les provinciaux de
reconnaître qu'î de France mobilité est
dans une situation un petit peu
particulière et puis troisièmement moi
je je suis ravi de cette PPL je félicite
son auteur mon collègue et ami capo je
le félicite parce
que il a accepté que je sois un des
premiers signataires et j'en suis ravi
et puis parce que je considère que cette
PL est juste euh elle est sociale et
elle prend en compte la réalité du
terrain nous étions avec le président
Longeot et avec Franck hier matin au au
dépôt de Montrouge et nous avons compris
l'attachement des salariés à leur dépôt
l'attachement des des salariés à leur à
leur
travail et puis je pe peut-être être un
de ceux qui peut témoigner des bienfaits
de l'ouverture à la concurrence puisque
je l'ai mené dans ma région sur le fait
ferroviaire et et et je sais ce que
l'ouverture à la concurrence peut amener
en en terme de je l'espère dans le futur
qualité de service mais au niveau de
l'augmentation du service à à un coût
plus raisonnable et le coût c'est la
vraie question aussi vous l'avez dit moi
tout comme vous je considère que et nous
aurons ce débat dans quelques jours sur
le PLF que plutôt que de faire porter
toute la charge du financement du
transport sur un seul il faut la
partager entre plusieurs bien sûr l'État
doit prendre sa sa part bien sûr les
collectivités vous l'avez obtenu doivent
participer bien sûr les
usagers de manière raisonnable mais qui
payeront toujours beaucoup moins que
leurs compatriotes européens qui sur
certains réseaux payent de tro quatre
fois plus cher que les prix opérés en
Île-de-France enfin les entreprises qui
je crois sont prêtes aussi à faire un
effort si elles sont associées ce sera
une de nos propositions de manière plus
directe à la
gouvernance de des autorités
organisatrices de de mobilité et
également si en contrepartie elles ont
pour leurs salariés un service public de
qualité voilà madame la Présidente pour
les questions vous y avez déjà répondu
merci cher Philippe je passe la parole à
Olivier
Jacquin merci président madame la
Présidente merci pour votre intervention
je j'observe que les délais d'examen de
ce texte de loi sont extrêmement
contraints et je félicite le rapporteur
d'avoir pris le dossier aussi rapidement
mais je regrette que les auditions vos
auditions ne soient pas ouvertes aux
membres de la commission ça faciliterait
dans céder les contraints notre travail
à tous c'était interne à à la commission
madame la Présidente alors vous avez
c'est intéressant de revenir sur un
texte de loi qui avait été voté qui a
montré ses limites et
on est dans une sorte de clause de
revoyure on a vu la difficulté de mise
en place de l'ouverture à la à la
concurrence même s'il y avait un fort
volontarisme et les très nombreux
désordres qu'ils ont engendré alors je
m'étonne de votre volonté de vouloir
obtenir là un délai qui reste somme
toute limité 2 ans et vous avez
justifier ça et je le comprends par les
élections municipales et les élections
présidentielles mais pourquoi ne
pas se donner plus de latitude pour
éviter de revenir une troisième fois
devant le législateur le cas échéant on
n'est pas garanti de la réussite et et
d'apaiser le le dossier il y a temps à à
faire que se laisser une marge de
manœuvre de temps et je pense qu'on
amendera en ce sens de vous donner plus
de possibilités de de de délai peut-être
intéressant la deè question et relative
à votre manière de lancer les appels
d'offre est-ce que la part prix n'a pas
été trop importante dans les notations
est-ce que vu les désordres qu'il y a eu
il ne faudrait pas enfin on vous suggère
je vous suggérerai peut-être de revoir
les critères de qualité d'analyse des
des
lots dans un dernier temps dernière
question sur les finances et c'est
extrêmement impressionnant le chiffre
que vous donnez de 200 milliard 7 euh
nécessaire en 2031 avec l'arrivée de
l'ensemble du réseau du Grand Paris
Express qui est assez incroyable et vous
solliciter la représentation
parlementaire pour avoir des idées de
recette euh monsieur capo Canada sait
par exemple que dans l'aérien il y a si
on veut opérer une justice climatique
évidente des gisements de recettes
manifestes dans l'aérien sans le mettre
par terre pour autant je sais avec
Vincent de lae pour avoir été dans la
commission d'enquête sur les profits
autoroutiers qu'il y a aussi là des
marges de manœuvre significative et
dernier point on a une chance historique
là en ce moment il y a un alignement des
astres avec le monde de l'entreprise qui
se voit supprimer les impôts de
production et il y a vraiment je pense à
engager une discussion comme l'a dit
Philippe taborau en amenant des
garanties qualitatives qu'attendre les
employeurs que ce soit pas un un tiroir
ouvert sans sans sans limite mais de
renégocier quelque chose on l'aligne
mandat c'est la suppression des impôts
de production mais c'est en même temps
l'arrivée de du réseau du Grand Paris
Express et là il y a vraiment des des
choses à faire je suis pas rassuré du
tout sur l'avenir mais vous non plus
visiblement parce que pour l'instant on
les a pas les 2 milliard 7 je vous
remercie très bien merci l on prendre
une dans cette série une troisème
question Louis Jean Nicolaï et puis
ensuite on aura de deux collègues oui
merci monsieur le Président tout est
tout a été dit et répondu je suis un peu
comme philippe Tabarot moi je voudrais
juste revenir sur deux choses et sur
notamment sur Paris intramuros est-ce
que c'est vraiment nécessaire de mettre
d'ouvrir la concurrence Paris
intramurose dans la pagaille dans lequel
c'est aujourd'hui où euh le métro est
plein je vois pas et des fil une minutes
3 minutes les uns des autres les bus
c'est assez compliqué de des horaires
des bus et autres et et et
l'augmentation est-ce qu'il faut encore
rajouter des voitures ou des ou des bus
dans dans Paris un TR muros voilà c'est
je je je pose cette question là sur la
sur la nécessité l'ouvrir ou pas Paris
un trurau c'est la
concurrence très bien Madame la
Présidente sur cette première série de
de questions alors sur sur les
questions de enfin qui n'existe pas de
philippe Tabarot mais j'y reviens quand
même il a dit il a dit on a eu un accord
de financement non on a un accord de
financement qui doit être validé par le
Parlement et dans cette période un peu
troublée euh on n'est jamais trop
prudent donc moi je suis venu aussi cet
après-midi au Sénat vous demander votre
soutien sur cet accord de financement
parce que je le crois proportionné je le
crois juste et je le crois équilibré
mais il est pas encore il n'est pas
encore adopté donc voilà moi j'aurais
besoin du soutien du Sénat sur cet
accord de financement je tiens à
préciser pour tous les sénateurs qui
sont là parce que je j'entends ce qui a
été dit sur la la province qui regarde
Paris qui se dit mais qu'est-ce que
c'est pourquoi tant d'argent et cetera
le Grand Paris Express a été financé par
les impôts des Franciliens taxes
d'équipement des ménag taxes sur les
bureaux le financement du Grand Paris
Express doit être financé par les
Franciliens ce qui s'est passé l'année
dernière avec 200 millions d'euros
d'argent de l'État qui est arrivé dans
les finances d'idfm que j'aurais dû
refuser mais je dois avouer
que quand on vous donne 200 millions
premier réflex c'est pas de dire non
j'aurais dû le refuser parce que j'ai vu
ensuite les réactions en chaînne de mes
collègues des autres régions et des
autres autorités qui ont dit mais
pourquoi on donne de millions à
l'île-de-fance et en fait de l'argent du
contribuable français moi je ne veux pas
l'argent du contribuable français je
veux que l'île-de-fance les le
contribuable francilien paye pour
l'île-de-fance je veux que les gens qui
profitent des transports franciliens
payent pour l'île-de-fance je veux pas
que ça que qu'on mette la contribution
les autres régions et c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans l'accord de financement
qu'on vous propose c'est que c'est nous
qui payerons pour nous-mêmes et et et et
c'est le juste c'est juste voilà et
c'est important et par ailleurs c'est
proportionnel aussi ben au 36 milliards
d'euros de nouvelle ligne qu'on va
ouvriroi quand même et je dis aussi un
deuxième chose aux sénateurs qui sont
intéressés au transport les
CERMES voter aussi peut-être un
amendement pour dire comment il vont
être financer leur
exploitation parce que moi c'est ça qui
nous implanté c'est qu'on a voté les
crédits d'investissement mais on n
absolument pas voté au moment où vot les
crédits d'investissement la part de
financement de l'exploitation donc quand
vous vous retrouverez avec vos CERMES
construits dans quelques années et que
vous devrez chercher qui paye et que
vous serez de vous dire je vais mettre
lestickets à je ne sais
combien voilà donc je vous invite à
retourner sur l'expérience du Grand
Paris pour Monsieur
Jacquin je dirais que en fait les
salariés ont aussi besoin de visibilité
et c'est anxiogène et j'en ai parlé avec
Jean Castex c'est anxiogène pour eux de
leur dire ça va durer 4 ans le processe
parce queil y a ceux qui passeront tout
de suitex ils vont être ils vont
connaître leur sort et puis il y a ceux
qui passeront dans 4 ans donc à un
moment donné il faut que le process il
soit quand même cadré dans le temps
c'est pour ça qu'on pense que 2 ans
c'est suffisant on a mis 3 ans pour 36
3 36 lot mis 3 ans là on a 12 lots on
dit 2 ans on prend son temps on prend
son temps on est zen on est serein on
est calme on prend notre temps mais
objectivement 2 ans c'est déjà long
c'est déjà assez long pour des
salariés le président de la TP lui-même
il était pour le report mais enfin il
disait parce que tant qu'on sait pas
quand on sait pas qui va nous arriver
c'est compliqué de se projeter donc
c'est pour ça qu'on veut pas trop longt
temps alors la par prix trop importante
la vérité c'est que la par prix c'est
plus que 40 % 40 % par prix 45 % pour la
technique et 15 % la clause sociale la
part sociale ce qui est unique en Europe
il y a pas un autre une autre ao qui met
autant de de poids sur la part sociale
et la vérité c'est que la part sociale
elle devient déterminante dans beaucoup
de contrats parce que sur le prix on est
allez à 5 % près on a les mêmes prix
donc on va pas chercher à Mo- 10 ans qui
ferait du low cost enfin ça existe pas
vous connaissez koolis vous connaissez
Transdev voilà c'est pas des mo-s 10 ans
sociaux c'est pas vrai voilà donc c'est
des sociétés qui sont d'ailleurs
publiques majoritairement publiqu donc
je pense que sur le prix la part du prix
est pas est pas est pas si importante
que qu'elle qu'elle n'y paraît euh voilà
et pour Louis-Jean Nicolaï je lui
réponds
alors on a fait mais ça s'est bien passé
donc quand ça se passe bien ça ne se
voit pas on a fait la refonte total du
Service Bus dans Paris intramuros il y a
quelques années quand je suis arrivé à
la tête de l'îne-france et on a fait
plus de 100 bu supplémentaires on a mis
on a mis 100 bu supplémentaires sur le
réseau parce qu'en fait on avait
beaucoup construit à l'Est et en
revanche au centre de Paris on était
encombré de ligne de bus à moitié vide
qui servait à rien donc on a refait tout
ce réseau de bus ça s'appelait le grand
Paris des bus euh donc ça toutes les
lignes aujourd'hui qui sont en
exploitation elles servent elles servent
à quelque chose on va pas en mettre plus
mais on les a elles sont bien le vrai
problème qu'on a à Paris c'est la
circulation mais ça ça ne dépend pas de
moi et si les bus roulent à 6 km he dans
Paris ça n'est pas de ma faute je je il
y a des trop de travaux et il y a trop
d'embouteillage et donc voilà mais ça
malheureusement je je ce n'est pas ma
compétence alors sur les réseaux de bus
r ATP il y a que de l'OT dans Paris hein
10 lots dehors de l'au 11 lots dehors de
l'eau dedans euh et les de l'OT
parisiens bah oui si quand même il vaut
mieux les mettre les ouvrir à la
concurrence c'est c'est jamais mauvais
mais la vérité sur les perturbations
dans Paris c'est qu'elles sont d à des
causes exogènes euh une bonne
partie merci pour ces réponses madame la
Présidente je vais laisser la parole
dans un premier temps à Pierre Barros et
puis à Pierre Jean Rochette pour la
question suivante et puis ensuite je
repasserai la parole à à Vincent
capocanas l'auteur de la proposition de
loi merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues bah oui je pense qu'en effet
améliorer les transports du quotidien
c'est le c'est l'enjeu et c'est la le
but de tous euh je pense qu'on est tous
condamnés à réussir parce que sinon la
catastrophe serait visible assez
rapidement avec des véhicules qui
arriveraiit en remplacement des des
lignes de bus donc et on l'a vécu ça des
lignes de bus qu'on eu des modifications
de des niveau de service sur des
secteurs purbains qui ont généré un
trafic routier automobile avec un
noncombrement des places de saçonnement
autour des gares donc on voit bien que
ce sujet peut être extrêmement tendu
s'il y a une toute petite distorsion je
dirais que le le mal arrive assez vite
et assez grand
euh en effet ce qui est important c'est
que les gens puissent partir de chez eux
arrivver à peu près à l'heure au travail
ce qui est demandé par tout le monde et
ce qui est plutôt pas plus mal et on a
un sujet aussi par rapport à la
discrimination territoriale parce qu'il
y a quand même des secteurs qui sont
assez mal desservis en terme de
transport en commun enfin en tout cas
qui sur le papier en tout cas sur les
plans sont bien desservis mais en tout
cas ça fonctionne tellement pas bien que
à la fin c'est à peu près le même
résultat que s'il avent pas grand-chose
donc c'est clair que c'est un challenge
important c'est une responsabilité
importante pour la région c'est un
cadeau un peu empoisonné des services
defin de l'État à une certaine époque et
je pense que la région en effet fait ce
qu'elle peut et ce qu'elle ce qu'elle
doit faire en tout cas pour régler ce
genre de sujet et j'ai j'apprécie
j'entends le tout le travail que vous
avez mené par rapport à je dirais le
l'accompagnement social des agents
j'espère que ça restera dans dans le
cadre du du projet de loi qu'il y aura
pas des amendements qui mettront à mal
ce cette ces engagement je trouve que
c'est quelque chose à surveiller de près
alors par contre c'est quand même un
coût et c'est vrai que nous on a dans le
temps nous était imp parti c'est vrai
qui a été assez court mais bon c'est un
sujet qui est très important pour
l'île-de-fance moi je suis sénateur du
valdoig dans dans le nord du du valdoise
d'ailleurs donc c'est quelque chose qui
me qui me tient aussi à cœur et c'est
vrai que le le tout ça n'est pas neutre
financièrement on a euh eu l'information
comme comme quoi il y aura un coût
d'environ 5 million d'euros 4 million ne
précisément donc là ça mériterait au
moins d'avoir une mission d'information
sur le financement de dispositif quand
même euh parce qu'il faut racheter des
biens de l' RATP sachant que pour le
coup le matériel roulant lui appartient
déjà à IDFM donc là-dessus il y a pas il
y a pas il y a pas de sujet donc c'est
vrai que ça pose quand même la question
du financement enfin le financement de
l'investissement
euh qui pour le vous l'avez rappelé la
situation financière d'ID FM n'est pas
si euh je dirais confortable que soit
euh que des gros projets
d'investissement portés donc euh CDG
Express et aut bon vous allez vous les
récupérer et ça va être sportif à gérer
à la fois en terme de fonctionnement et
en effet euh c'est une c'est une très
bonne nouvelle pour les francillens mais
c'est financièrement un coût
supplémentaire pour IDFM et c'est vrai
que c'est pas fait
euh et que
euh ça correspond grosso modo à 3 ans
d'investissement du budget d'idfm hein
ce qui est quand même assez colossal sur
sur cette part là donc c'est clair que
les partenaires qui vont nous permettre
enfin vous permettre de financer tout ça
ont déjà enfin vous l'avez dit hein les
représentation des des entreprises on ne
souhaite pas mettre la main à la poche
sur le sur le versement en mobilité ceci
dit je suis assez d'accord avec les
collègues c'est vrai que les
collectivités comme comme celle dont on
nous sommes issus vont perdre la CVAE et
que c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour
les entreprises bon il faudra peut-être
qu'un ce soit un peu donnant donnant sur
la façon dont elles peuvent participer à
l'amélioration d'un truc qui est qui
leur est tout à fait proche c'est de
faire en sorte que le leurs salariés
puissent les rejoindre sur les temps de
travail euh l'augmentation du Pass
Navigo c'est un sujet aussi parce qu'à
un moment donné c'est vrai qu'on peut
l'augmenter mais quand est-ce que ça va
s'arrêter et à partir de là c'est vrai
que l'équation financière ne peut pas
reposer que sur la la
terriification aux utilisateurs reste
l'État et donc là c'est un bras de fer
vous avez l'habitude de ça je vous
laisserai juge sur la question de la
stratégie et retour d'expérience par
rapport à la grande couronne bon moi
j'ai un avis un tout petit peu différent
de de votre retour d'expérience
évidemment si vous pouvez poser les
questions Plô juste quand même le retour
d'expérience c'est intéressant parce que
je l'ai vécu une stress qu' y a quelques
semaines quelques mois sur la rentrée où
j'avais quasiment plus de bus plus son
son secteur kolice les collègues qui
sont sur Transdev me racontent la même
chose donc il y a un changement de on
était sur un changement de marché euh
des études ont été réalisées j'ai des
modifications du des réseaux et à partir
de là c'était pour les collèges pour les
lycées pour les enfin pour tout le monde
c'était extrêmement compliqué et pour le
coup quand ça déconne c'est pas ID FM
qu'on appelle c'est les mairies je pe
vous assuré que les services publics les
accueillent ils en ont pris plein les
dents euh et et on a dû jouer très fort
sur sur nos réseaux pour essayer de
trouver des solutions et c'est pas si
simple donc la question de l'ouverture
la concurrence bon c'est c'est un sujet
on peut voir les choses d'une manière
différente et notamment partir sur un
fonctionnement de régie régionale c'est
possible la loi
l'autorise comme ce qui va d'ailleurs
être mis en place pour le métro me
semble-t-il euh je pense que Monsieur
Castex que vous allez auditionner demain
matin va peut-être vous évoquer le sujet
euh la régime for droit l' r étap pour
le coup pourrait se reccentrer sur les
sujets d'île-de-fance plutôt que de
perdre son temps à l'étranger sur des
sujets qui sont jeblé de passer à la
question suivante euh voilà et puis
après ça le calendrier en effet j'ai
compris qu'il fallait aller très vite je
pense qu'on pourrait prendre un peu plus
de temps pour pour faire les choses
peut-être de manière plus plus
tranquille merci excusez-moi merci donc
pierre jeanrochette pour la question
suivante oui merci bonjour madame la
Présidente juste une question j'ai bien
entendu le sujet sujet évoqué sur le
découpage des lots je voudrais savoir
quelle est la place des non je suis pas
de la région du tout Île-de-France si
c'était la question je voudais savoir
quelle est la place des PME indépendante
dans cette ouverture à la concurrence
parce que les lots en général sont de
taillees effectivement vous l'avez
souligné vous avez raison et je pense
qu'on peut pas l'aborder non plus avec
des approches micro microolot ça ne
fonctionnerait pas mais quelle est la
place des PME dans cette ouverture la
concurrence et comment avons-nous la
certitude de préserver aussi ce maillage
de PME régional indépendante en région
Île-de-France à travers l'ouverture de
la la concurrence deuxième petite
question très rapide comment
envisagez-vous l'aspect
patrimonial quant aux dépôts parce qu'on
sait que c'est un élément qui limite
considérablement la concurrence dans les
appels d'offre et qu'aujourd'hui
alors Paris intramurose bien entendu je
suppose que le sujet vite réglé mais sur
toutes les toutes les lignes qui sont
exploitées en dehors de de Paris
intramuros quelle est la politique
d'Île-de-France mobilité en terme de
détention des
dépôts aujourd'hui il y a pas de
concurrence possible sur des zones aussi
denses que la région Île-de-France s'il
n'y a pas de de mise à disposition des
dépôts merci voilà je vais laisser la
parole donc à l'auteur de la proposition
de loi Vincent merci monsieur le
Président quelques mots d'abord pour
vous remercier de de m'accueillir c'est
une habitude sur les sujets qui qui
concerne les transports et qui ont un
contenu social important c'était le cas
sur les contrôleurs du ciel il y a
quelques semaines proposition loi qui
qui avance à l'Assemblée euh je reviens
toujours devant vous avec plaisir
quelques mots la présidente a dit
beaucoup de choses euh un d'abord ce qui
n'est pas dans dans la proposition de
loi la partie financement d' de France
mobilité elle viendra au stade du PLF
donc on aborde la question mais c'est
pas dans dans la proposition loi premer
point deuxème point il y a un triptique
si je puis le résumer ainsi d'abord un
temps nécessaire pour réussir cette
ouverture à la concurrence deuxièmement
un sac à dos social qui est aussi
nécessaire et troisièmement une volonté
forte de réussir cette ouverture pour
les passagers mais aussi avec les
salariés et au bénéfice des territoires
et de la mobilité c'est ça la démarche
ok vous aviez travaillé beaucoup sur la
Lom à l'époque dans cette Commission et
au Sénat a tous travaillé là-dessus mais
on pouvait pas anticiper toutouses les
difficulté la présidente a rappelé les
acquis du travail qui mené IDFM et de
l'expérience qui a déjà été mené
concrètement OK et donc on voit bien que
il y avait un C nombre de points de
réglage qui ont pu être approchés
paridfm quand on parle quandme de la
densité du du réseau la la la présidente
faisait la référence à Rennes par
exemple au Nantes il y a il y a pas
d'exemple je crois de comme ça quand
même de de de sujets majeurs et qu'on
avait prévu en une fois hein c'était
quand même ça le le texte de loi à
l'époque bon voilà donc un temps
nécessaire vous l'avez rappelé sur le le
nombre de salariés le nombre de dépôts
de bus le nombre de points d'arrêt enfin
on parle de quelque chose ne serace que
1300 points d'arrêt plus de 4800 bus
c'est pas rien avec tout le système
d'info qui était RATP qui doit basculer
pour parti chez IDFM il faudra intégrer
les les nouveaux exploitants bon la
billeéthique l'information du voyageur
ENF il y a plein de de sujets concrets
qu'il faut arriver à à traiter quelques
points juste sur les aspects sociaux le
le rapporteur que je salue et que je
remercie d'avoir pris ça au vol euh
ainsi que philippe Tabarot avec qui j'ai
beaucoup travaillé qui est mon premier
coignat làdessus qui connaitt
excellemment bien ces sujets il y a
qu'un défaut par rapport à moi c'est que
lui n'est pas francilien donc voilà don
c'est pour ça que c'est moi qui qui qui
suis premier de cord si je dire parce
que c'est quand même un sujet très
franilien
mais la notion de de dépôt de centrebus
pour les les les machinistes pour les
les les conducteurs elle est majeure ok
donc on on le prend compte et c'était
pas dans dans la Lom donc il faut
l'introduire c'est ce qu'on fait ici bon
ce pointl et enfin ce sont des métiers
exigeants être machiniste c'est aussi
travailler le weekend c'est travailler
la nuit c'est travailler tôt donc il
faut prendre en compte ça quand la
présidente dit que les questions de
déplacement questions de de domicile
pour eux ce sont des questions majeures
c'est vrai bon enfin c'est assurer la
quantité du service c'est quand même la
base pour nous et on voit bien que si on
ne change pas les dispositions
législatives on aura du mal ne serait-ce
qu'à assurer la quité du service enfin
pour je terminerai là-dessus on a besoin
de machiniste et on voit bien dans la
période récente présidente l'a très bien
rappelé que malgré tous les efforts qui
sont faits ça reste c'est un enjeu TP me
disait que le le plan porte le plan de
recrutement ok mais on voit bien que
l'attention que nous donnons elle est
nécessaire et pour tout dire je pense
que ce que nous faisons ce nous allons
essayer de faire ensemble c'est de
clarifier unensble de points qui seront
utiles à tous y compris d'ailleurs aux
exploitants parce que les exploitants
quels qu'ils soit d'abord IDFM en a
besoin ok nous avons tous besoin
d'éviter les aléas mais les exploitants
aussi et les candidats n'ont pas envie
qu'il y ait des aléas il y a rien de
pire dans un contrat donc on essaie de
manière pragmatique de de retisser un N
de points pour permettre que tout ça
réussisse pour le bénéfice de tous merci
beaucoup Vincent madame la
présidenteel monsieur le Président alors
dans déjà je vous demande de bien
vouloir m'excuser parce que je vais
filer comme une voleuse par que à moins
le quart je suis attendu dans le bureau
du président du Sénat avec beaucoup de
respect mais je voudrais dire vraiment
alors je voudrais répondre à Pierre
Baros lui dire que effectivement il y a
5 milliards
d'euros de transfert de transfert de de
biens qui qui arriveront dans lescarcell
d'idfm à l'issue de l'ouverture à la
concurrence pourquoi parce qu'en fait
avant on achetait les matériels roulants
mais c'est nous qui les payons de toutes
les façons on les paye on les achetait
et ils partaiit dans les dépôts de la
RATP là aujourd'hui on va les racheter
on va racheter tous ceux qu'on avait pas
déjà acheté on va les racheter donc
effectivement il y a il y a un coût mais
ce coup en fait de tout façon on l'urait
payé d'une manière ou d'un autre on
l'aurait payé parce que c'est nous qui
achetons les matériels roulants donc en
fait c'est c'est c'est un faux coût
pardon c'est un peu une agitation des
des syndicats pour dire ça va coûter de
l'argent l'ouverture la concurrence en
fait non parce que la loi a changé nous
sommes désormais propriétaire du
matériel rouant tous les bus c'est nous
qui les achetons et on en est
propriétaire alors ils sont à la RATP
aujourd'hui ils seront chez nous demain
mais c'est c'est comptable en fait on
les achète c'est c'est nous qui les
payons et alors donc les les 5 milliards
d'euros donc de de d'investissement sont
à mettre au regard des 4 milliards
d'euros d'investissement annuels d'idfm
donc c'est pas énorme c'est c'est voilà
et nous on veut être propriétaire du
matériel roulant parce que c'est
important et ça me permet de répondre à
la question de Monsieur Rochette c'est
qu'on on va aussi être propriétaire des
dépôt de bus avec l'ouverture la
concurrence on devient propriétaire des
dépôts de bus donc on en fait et on va
alors la question que vous soulevez est
une question intéressante qui qui nous
amènerait vers des débats beaucoup plus
longs c'est de dire et est-ce qu'on
aurait pas dû choisir de faire une Régie
régionale mais moi j'étais pas hostile
sauf que la Régie régionale s'appelle
île- defance mobilité parce que dans le
cadre du Grand Paris Express où toutes
les nouvelles lignes de métro sont
ouvertes à la concurrence et où déjà
Keolis a gagné la ligne 16 euh bon la
RATP a gagné la ligne 15 donc en fait on
va avoir des opérateurs multiples donc
en fait ce qui serait logique et ce qu'
fait c'est pas ce qu' choisi le
Parlement c'est pas que choisi le
gouvernement mais c'est que toute
l'infrastructure soit gérée par de
France mobilité et que la Régie
régionale ça devienne nous alors si vous
me poussez sur les prise de
participation étrangère de la RATP voilà
on pourra discuter on sera peut-être pas
loin de trouver un accord mais ça c'est
un autre sujet ça c'est un autre
sujet et qui qui dépasse un petit peu le
voilà et sur les PME indépendantes grâce
à l'ouverture la concurrence on a fait
émerger un groupe indépendant familial
savaac la croix qui est issu de de la
fusion de groupe Lacroix du Valoise et
du groupe SAVAC des Yvelines qui
maintenant a les épaules pour candidater
pour ce genre d'appel d'offre en on a
aussi des sous-traitants dans lead qui
travaillent avec les grands groupes dans
dans le cadre de ces appels
d' merci à tous merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente pour cette audition et puis
je remercie bien sûr notre collègue
rapporteur et l'auteur de la proposition
ainsi que chacune
d'entre